welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Aisha Ramachandran an assistant
professor of comparative literature at
Yale University
she's a literary and cultural historian
of early modern Europe and primarily
concerned with transnational encounters
and the early mechanisms of
globalization from the late 15th to the
early 18th centuries today we'll talk
with Professor Ramachandran about her
book the world makers global imagining
in early modern Europe
welcome professor Ramachandran thanks so
much for having me all right let's start
with an overview of your book and this
is your first book yes this is okay
congratulations
so give us an overview of it and what
the premise is so the book is largely
about the culture and literature and new
science of early modern Europe so 16th
and 17th centuries and it's interested
in the way the concept world as a
comprehensive category of totality and
everything came to have its modern form
so we think of this term as being
completely self explanatory we think of
it as referring to our globe we think of
it as you know individual worlds we
think of it as having both multiple
meanings and particular Geographic
meanings and we often don't think that
this idea itself that this term world
means these things has a history and so
my book is really teasing out the
history of the sturm and attempting to
go back to the moment of the kind of
very beginning of globalization to think
about how we evolved this modern concept
of world okay and what was the kernel
that you know sparked the book for you
you know it's such a funny story I wrote
my dissertation on imagined worlds in
literary texts so my PhD is in
Renaissance Studies a very kind of
literary topic and so I was interested
in fictional works in the 16th and 17th
century that imagined other worlds then
I asked myself well why do all these
texts have these weird otherworldly
imaginings in it and so as somebody
who's very interested in history
whose training is broadly historical I
began to think more about this question
why do these sort of artifacts these art
and sort of literary objects begin to
think in these otherworldly terms and of
course one very obvious answer is well
this is the moment of the expansion of
the world discovery of the Americas new
planets all of these things and then I
also discovered that just lexically in
terms of language what the meaning of a
term like world meant radically changes
and so before the sixteenth century
world still refers to the thing that God
made it's an it's an idea can very
closely linked to a theological concept
and it also has moral over difference so
somebody who is worldly somebody who's
corrupt and too interested in things of
the world and material things and not
interested enough in spiritual matters
and then something changes in the 16th
and 17th century when that theological
spiritual moral idea gives way to a more
what we might say kind of secular
Geographic it's an economic commercial
idea and so I became very interested in
tracing that shift and on the other hand
I in my field in literary studies but
also in history we've been very
interested in the last 25 years in
globalization but that global eye that
turn towards globalization has been
driven largely by interests in economic
history in political histories broadly
say histories of sort of society and
migration but there hasn't been that
much attention to the kind of conceptual
question of you know how do we even get
to thinking in global terms right we
think about Europe being a kind of small
closed world to itself that it can then
imagine something that is bigger than
itself and the kind of complexities
intellectually and philosophically that
come into play so my book in some ways
is a counterpoint to studies of
globalization that think largely in
these sorts of economic commercial
political terms and offers a more I
would say kind of a philosophical
cultural compliment to thinking about
those questions okay and how do you how
did you do them what was a methodology
for the book how did you do the research
so this is a book that is odd in some
ways because it doesn't quite fit into
any clear discipline it's a very
interdisciplinary book it moves from
looking at the cartographic revolutions
or the making of the four
world maps to thinking about the first
autobiographies to thinking about epic
poetry to thinking about the new science
to thinking about the kind of conflict
between religion and science so it makes
it draws on a number of different fields
and part of that is my training as
somebody in a very in Renaissance study
is the set of hybrid interdisciplinary
degree and also somebody who is very
interested conceptually in going back to
this pre enlightenment moment when we
did not have disciplines and the way we
understand them today so the methodology
of the book is itself an attempt to get
past these disciplinary barriers that in
some ways make it difficult for us to
recover this kind of more amorphous
history and so it's partly historical
it's partly philosophical it's partly
literary analysis and it so I would if I
had to really give it a kind of
disciplinary clarity I would say it's
somewhere between history and philosophy
with a lot of literary methodology
thrown in okay but on the other hand I
look at a lot of visual text so so it's
it's its goal really is to cut past what
I think of as a kind of deep
intellectual historical divide around
the 18th century when we began to have
the separate disciplines where you could
not write a kind of comprehensive
multifaceted history of anything because
you were really increasingly narrow and
specialized and that's the history of
our Academy - so this book is an attempt
to kind of push past that to go back
into the kind of head of the 16th
century scholar who thought in this more
kind of multi-faceted way and so the
book brings that to bear okay so you're
starting basically in the 1600s yes so
in the 1500s in the 16th century
so what were the earliest Inklings that
became apparent to you for this changing
kind of way to look at the world so the
most obvious place people go for this is
of course the discovery of this the
so-called discovery of the new world
right I mean when Europeans come to the
Americas for the first time there is the
sense that oh my god there is this other
big continent of course it takes about
150 years for people to even realize
that is the constant right and you know
what is a continent is itself an idea
that's in flux but one of the less I
mean it's not just the excitement of
finding you know this
new source of wealth and you know all of
the kind of really horrific things that
go with European colonization at that
point but there are other important
conceptual changes that that brings
about for instance Europeans thought
that they knew what things were like in
their world and so the sort of eruption
of the New World and European
consciousness is also a sign that we
don't know and that perhaps we cannot
know and perhaps our certainties and all
these other areas are also possibly
under attack it's just that we haven't
quite gotten that knowledge yet so
there's a kind of double sense of real
terror the fact that all our old
certainties are perhaps not so certain
and also a real excitement that there is
the possibility for these things we
didn't know for us to know them now
right so that moment is conceptual it's
not just the kind of fact of discovery
but it's the conceptual consequences of
discovery that I'm really interested in
right it also means other things it
means that well you know why does the
Bible not describe these people of the
new world and where did they come from I
mean how did Adams successors get across
the Atlantic I mean it is creates all of
these questions that to us seem kind of
crazy questions to reven are be asking
but they disturb really fundamental ways
that people imagine the cosmos was was
organized so that's the kind of first
moment and then out of that come all of
these new kinds of questions that in
themselves lead to new sorts of inquiry
okay and you look at specific people
throughout history and those are the
world makers so let's talk a lot about
this turmoil makers which in some ways
historians find somewhat anachronistic
because it's a term that's closely
linked to contemporary philosophy as a
way of looking at the world not as being
this kind of realistic thing but the
possibility that our experience of the
world is subjective perspective oh but I
I find that the history of that term
world Maker is actually very old one and
it's one that's born in the late 16th
century as people came to use that word
in English for the first time to talk
about the idea that the world is made
right that it's actually an artifact so
the term world maker is invented in the
late 16th century and it's not it's it's
a part of hybrids like playwright and
wheelwright and Cartwright right people
who make something so the
idea then and said the world is
something that is made it was previously
believed to have been made by God and
were in a period in which people are
beginning to wonder if the world can be
made by humans right and so that
conceptual shift is part of what I'm
interested in in using this term world
make us the people I talk about and I
really talk about five different figures
who become representative of particular
fields in which this kind of major
intellectual shift is happening so the
first person I talked about is Gerhard
Mercator who we know from the Mercator
projection the projection that were made
possible navigation across deep deep
ocean water navigation who made this map
in the late 16th century that we now
think of as being this kind of iconic
map of the world but marketers life and
his career tracks the entire 16th
century so and his interest in imagining
both what the world and the cosmos look
like is goes beyond the geographic he's
very interested in theological questions
interested in kind of cosmic what we
might think of as physics right now so I
look at this through the lens of his
life and work I both trace how the image
of the world on a map comes to be born
in the 16th century like how does that
vision of the world that we think of on
maps be drawn for the first time when
you have to remember that people like
Mercator never went anywhere they lived
in the same small places in Europe they
gathered information from sailors and
diplomats and drawings of friends and
and made these maps as this kind of
supreme feat of imagination I mean today
we have you know GPS and satellites and
pictures from outer space but until the
Apollo expedition in the late 60s we
have no actual corroboration that these
maps that would be began to be made in
the 16th century actually looked
anything like what the earth looked like
right so I'm interested in the kind of
imaginative leap that links to Science
and Mathematics in the spirit that
produces this new vision of the world
and then I look at a very famous French
humanist figure Michel de Montaigne who
is book the essays I could be considered
one of the first modern are
autobiographies and but I'm interested
in how autobiography which is really the
writing of oneself and one individual in
Martin's work becomes a kind of writing
of the world
so the way
which people talk about the world in
terms of cosmography literally writing
the world become the ways in which
month-end
talks about the self so the self becomes
a mirror of the world but also an
extension of it right so there's this
kind of interesting reconstruction of
the relationship between the individual
and the surrounding world that happens
in these essays and so I tease that out
I have a third chapter that looks at the
epic poems of Edmund Spenser a kind of
important English epic poet and cowboy
an important Portuguese epic poet and
commercial poem is about the discovery
of the sea route to India and Spencer's
poem is an imagination of what British
Empire might look like long before but
never had an empire so that this becomes
a chapter where I look at these epic
poems that imagine versions of Empire
both historical and imagined and I use
that to think about how world making is
fundamentally the prelude to what will
become the imperial projects of the 18th
century and beyond so I think they're
about how I the idea of the world is
both conducive to Empire but also Dwarfs
Empire right so they're kind of skills
of of order we have the nation we have
Empire and we have world and I think
about how these three terms actually are
constantly in interplay in the period I
didn't have a chapter on Descartes kind
of a major sort of father of modern
philosophy but I write des cartes very
first work that he kind of held onto for
his entire life that we never published
is the work called the world and he was
about to publish it in 1632 when Galileo
was placed under house arrest and so he
suppresses the publication of this work
called the world but that the work he
did the scientific work that went into
this kind of reimagine ation and really
of what we would now call physics so
what was called national philosophy went
into all of his other major works so we
know the discourse on method and we know
the meditations and the work that really
underpins these kind of watershed texts
and the history of philosophy and
science come out of this work that he
called the world and so I'm interested
in kind of recreating why it is that he
called this work the world how this work
actually mirrors genesis itself and how
kind of he realized how complicated
would be to publish something like this
in the climate of the 1630s and why that
work then takes
this different form and dicots other
writings so I'm sort of teased out here
again the beginnings of the new science
and its connection to these older ideas
of philosophy and how it Beavs the way
for other ways of thinking both
scientifically and in terms of the
conflict between religion and science
and the final chapter is on John
Milton's Paradise Lost and I come to
this text that everybody knows in reads
in school in college and in school by
really asking the question why should we
write a poem about Genesis in the late
1660s you know this is well pastor
Copernicus it's prostate card where in
the world of the new science why go back
to this creation story and so I argue
here that Paradise Lost is really a
rewriting of Genesis for a post
Cartesian age then what happens when we
have this new version of world Milton is
the first poet one might say to imagine
an infinite universe where Milton's
universe is expansive spacious infinite
and how does that square with narratives
of Genesis that have seemed to be in
conflict with this new idea of the
cosmos and of the world not just
understood as our earth but understood
as our universe so I look there again at
the kind of imaginative play that's
required in some ways to hold on both to
the idea of religion and create creation
stories but also what it means to kind
of embrace the new imagination of an
infinite universe so through the course
of your studying these time periods can
you pinpoint or not necessarily pinpoint
but approximate when we finally kind of
had a close approximation to what we
think of as the world now that's a great
question um so I think it's a two-step
process I think by the end of the
sixteenth century we have a pretty good
sense of our world as an earth as a kind
of Geographic idea and ice and that sort
of roughly corresponds to the rise of
the world atlas as a genre a new kind of
book and I think the second phase of
that is the expansion of that Geographic
concept out of the kind of sphere of the
earth into the into the cosmos and that
is what we see in the 17th century so I
think that they're these kind of two
watershed moments where for the first
time people understand the world to be a
combination literally of land
water I mean in geography before the
late 16th century you think of land and
water as two separate things you don't
think of them as kind of a hybrid
integrated body and that conceptual
shift is the kind of first important
moment and then to kind of push that
imagination outward into the universe's
the second and so one nice example of
this is Columbus become such an
important figure in the narratives of
discovery right I mean he's the one who
crossed the ocean and that image of
Columbus the discoverer is an image
that's adopted by Galileo but he speaks
of his own discovery of the you know of
Jupiter and the moons of Jupiter and
that sense of expanding this terrestrial
metaphor of you know sailors going to
other places into the universe right I
mean that you think of these angels and
Milton's decks traversing space as being
sailors across the oceans right I mean
it's the kind of import of one kind of
metaphor into another sphere that also
suggests quite literally a kind of
imaginative expansion so what you
conclude ultimately in your book and
what would you like
readers to take away from your book so I
think two things I mean this is in some
ways this is a descriptive history it's
an attempt to kind of recover a way of
thinking that we have come to take for
granted completely and so I I guess I
might I would say that two takeaways I
mean one is this is the book that
responds to a transformative moment now
we are I think very much in a kind of
similar moment of trying to tease out
how that idea of world might itself be
changing I think much of the emphasis on
an interest in globalization comes out
of this this sort of attempt to make
sense of our own moment and the kinds of
radical changes that we see and part of
what I want to suggest is that our sense
of flux today when we confronted with
the idea of globalization itself has a
history I mean if we go back and think
of that problem itself historically we
might recognize some of the strategies
that were used you know four hundred
years ago that paradoxically we find
ourselves using so I end the book
actually by thinking about Google Earth
and the fascination that people have
with using Google Earth as being
analogous to the excitement of people
using the first maps in the world and
both atlases right what does that mean
of our own sense of ourselves in space
and so I I really do believe that one of
the things that historical study
offers us is that sense of reflecting on
where we are now
the second really important thing take
away I think from the book is that we
have spent so much time thinking about
concepts like world in largely what I
would call social science terms in terms
of economics politics and and that's
really important and of course
crucial in terms the way our lives are
structured what we have lost and what I
think that someone like me working in
comparative literature can bring to the
question is the kind of imaginative
conceptual work that underlies the
making of these big concepts and so my
book bases a lot of emphasis on the kind
of imaginative and speculative leaps
that people have to make to get from one
theoretical paradigm to another but it
not just material sort of shifts of
institutions and nations but people have
to actually imagine themselves there
first right I mean science doesn't just
happen it's because some people someone
actually sat down and thought I can do
this differently let me think about how
and there are lot of mistakes along the
way so far what my book wants to recover
is that sense of excitement the kind of
importance of the imagination the
importance of conceptual speculation all
of which we now think of as being kind
of in the humanities or kind of related
to the arts and this is a book that
really talks about the kind of
integrated work that the arts and the
sciences do together
the importance of speculation and the
imagination for diplomacy and politics
right and we have separated those two
things out and part of the takeaway of
the book I think is how much we have to
gain from going back and kind of
bringing those relationships back
together
very good thank you so much for being
here with us today thank you so much for
having me okay for more information
about professor or Ramachandran and her
work please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale